hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me
hi guys it's quinn again and today we're
going to discuss a topic that people
bring up to me
a lot and even people that have read the
entire dune saga a lot of people are
kind of fuzzy on this so we're going to
talk about the metamorphosis of paul
atreides's son
later the second
and the
ramifications of it
uh the personal ramifications of it
specifically
and the reasons behind it and also the
way it happened and how he was able to
do this
so to understand it we have to start
with the bitty jesuit the order of women
that have been secretly manipulating the
bloodlines of various people in the dune
universe for
thousands of years so they've been in
jesuit have
extreme control over their internal
chemistry they can control their
internal chemistry down to a molecular
level they can remove poisons they can
convert substances into other substances
within their body so they have this
extreme control
and paul atreides was trained in the
vinnie jesuit way because his mother was
a beni jesuit and she was attempting to
produce the quizets had iraq by having
him and training him in the vinnie
jesuit way
now paul's children lato angonema
because of their genes which were
manipulated by the benny jesuit
in addition to the
spice heavy diet that their mother was
on
during the pregnancy
were preborn um and the book children of
dune is largely about
the ramifications of someone being
pre-born and how they struggle against
the multitude of lives that live within
them because when someone is pre-born
they are born
with the memories of all of their
ancestors so there's all of these other
people that have lived in their mind so
they don't really have a solid ground
they don't really have a solid basis for
personality they're not a person
themselves and so often
what happens is what the benny jesuit
have named abomination and this is when
one of the inner lives becomes the
dominant
mind in this person and it's usually
it's usually a malignant
mind it's usually like a crazed mind for
instance
spoiler alert paul's sister aaliyah who
is also pre-born in the book children of
dune succumbs to abomination and she is
possessed by the ego memory of the baron
who is
spoiler alert her grandfather she is
he's the grandfather of paul and leah in
case you didn't know that and so she
succumbs to that
so throughout children of dune you have
lato and gennima
recognizing the fact that their aunt has
been possessed by the baron
and wondering if they too can avoid
becoming eventually possessed by some
ego memory within their own mind
now
because of the fact that they are
pre-born
these children are also born with the
memories of their ancestors and so
they're they've also inherited benny
jesuit memories so
like paul
like their grandmother jessica they too
possess the same internal
control that benny jesuit possessed
and that is crucial in how later the
second was able to become
what he became the warm god emperor
so on arrakis
there are creatures known as sand trout
and they're basically these little
creatures that basically swim around in
the sand
and insist water
the sand trout are actually the proto
life form
of the sand worms so eventually a bunch
of sand trout will become a single worm
they kind of come together and become a
worm eventually it's part of its life
cycle
so later the second because of his mini
jesuit inherited abilities
is able to take the sand trout
manipulate his own
chemistry in such a way
to allow
a symbiotic relationship to form so he
allowed the sand trout to
basically
fuse to him and become a part of his
body
now in the early stages of this it was
more like a sand trout skin
think if you're a fan of comics the
symbiote from
venom it was more of a skin
and as the millennia went on
the metamorphosis
continued and he became
more worm-like
now that's the how
now let's move on to the why and a lot
of people know the basic why which is
because to save humanity he did it to
save humanity but why
was this
the way
now
the basic reason is because this was the
only way
to live 4 000 years and to be able to
see
his plans through essentially because
lato like paula tradies was prescient
and arguably his prescience was even
clearer than paul etrey's especially
once he took on the sand trout skin
so later like his father paul obviously
saw that humanity was headed
for
an extinction event and not just an
extinction event a devastating painful
cruel extinction event
and he needed to live long enough to see
that his plan to board it would actually
be
seen through
and the fact that he was on arrakis and
that he would be in a worm body also
added to this because the worms of
arrakis are central
to
the imperium right so the spice the
guild navigators need needed to navigate
you can't travel without spice
plenty of people throughout the imperium
were addicted to spice and spice
withdrawals were deadly
so spice is very important therefore the
worms are very important because they're
kind of at the center of all human
events so later takes this being which
is at the center of all human events and
makes it into a god
so
it really is still at the center of all
human events and iraq is is still at the
center of all human events not because
it's the place where spice is produced
because in the distant futures another
spoiler alert it's no longer the place
where spice is produced because it's
terraformed but it's still the center of
all human events because that's now
where the worm god lives the last worm
now of course the worm in the form of
shyhalud was already a god to the fremen
but lato took this kind of aesthetic
and brought it to essentially the masses
um and enforced the worship
so laketoe was essentially
harnessing the spiritual force of
something that was once
purely
an economic thing mostly
and actually neil gaiman does a great
job in his book american gods of
discussing you know what is
a god
necessarily is it is a god you know thor
or yahweh or can a god
be
an idea
can a god be
a system because if you look at the
modern world
people are worshiping traditional gods
less and less and worshipping other
things like social media
or just like a fandom or
conspiracy theory
what is really holding people's
attention what is really captivating
them and what are they dedicating a
spiritual amount of attention to what
are they devoting themselves to what are
they devoting their lives to and i say
they but i mean we because i'm a human
too obviously you know
it's not it's not traditional gods
anymore that's less and less
so lato took
so lato took something
that wasn't divine in the traditional
sense but was divine in this kind of
nuisance
this spice trade this worm and he
took it in a different direction and
roped it back around
and said let me take it back to this
original sense and show you how bad it
is to worship anything and show you how
bad it is to be dependent on anything
i'm gonna take this thing that doesn't
speak and i'm gonna give it a voice and
i'm gonna show you it's true horror
so
that's why lato did what he did
now let's talk about the actual cost to
him so because he does this he is denied
a life of his own an actual human
existence of his own he has access to
all of these other all of these other
inner lives within his mind but he can
never have a human experience himself
with his own body
uh the the sand trout skin rejects water
he can't moisture
is like acid to him
so he can't have a lover he doesn't have
a penis and yes that's discussed in the
books too
um he can't really have human
intimacy
and
he also has to appear
as a god as something that is far above
humanity so he can't really like express
any form of humanity openly and as the
years go on he gradually becomes less
and less human he's simultaneously the
most human and the least human at the
same time because he has all these inner
lives and he has this intimate
deep understanding of human humanity and
what it is to be human but he can never
ever experience it firsthand and he's
tortured because of it it's tragic i
mean god ever of dune is straight up a
tragedy
so i think i covered everything that i
wanted to cover in this video
make sure you like and subscribe for
more quince ideas and if you have any
more questions about the lore of dune
or questions about the lore of other
science fiction series leave them in the
comment section below and if another if
enough people ask the same question or
if i'm intrigued enough by the question
i might make a video on the topic thank
you so much for watching
by the way i totally make graphic novels
and if you want to support me in this
channel then you can totally buy one off
my website thank you so much
[Music]
you